انا طلعت حاولت اتاجر بره لقيت اقل ادنى
سعر الايجار 350 شيكل وانا ما قدرتش ادفع
350 شيكل شايف الوضع الاقتصادي كيف انا
طبيعه شغلي بشتغل على الكورنيش بحر غزه 15
شيكل وخميس وجمع عشرين شيكل اوقات بروحش
عشان اوفر السبع شيكل المواصلات
على فكره وحياه اللي خلقك عشان احنا منقلت
الموت احنا مش عايشين والله لولو احنا مش
عايشين اصلا
تشهد غزه نموا ديموغرافيا متزايدا وسطا
محدوديه الامكانات المتاحه ليصل عدد
السكان الى مليونين
و30000 تقريبا في القطاع في مساحه جغرافيه
صغيره تتناقص اراضيها الزراعيه يوما بعد
يومه بسبب الزحف العمراني وتمدد العائلات
ما يجعله من اكثر الاماكن عشوائيه وكثافه
سكانيه في العالم
[موسيقى]
يعيشون على ارض صغيره مساحتها لا تزيد عن
365 كيلو متر مربع اي ان متوسط المساحه
للفرد هي 150 متر مربع هذه المساحه الضيقه
هي مساحه لاقامه انشطه السكن والانشطه
الثقافيه والاجتماعيه والرياضيه والسياحيه
والتجاريه هذه المساحه غير كافيه عملنا
على العديد من الاجراءات
لمعالجه ازمه الاسكان بدايه
تطوير انظمه الابنيه الموجوده
حيث سمحنا باضافه ضابط اضافي على المباني
الموجوده وهذا من باب التوسع الراسي اضافه
الى تطوير العشوائيات
وايضا تعزيز المناطق الحدوديه
[موسيقى]
مقبره الشيخ شعبان هي الاقدم في مدينه غزه
اتخذ منها عشرات العوائل ملاذا ومهربا من
ازمه السكن الخانقه في القطاع التي باتت
ازمه حقيقيه فالحاجه مستمره والمتوفر ثابت
لا يتغير من مساحه لعدد الاراضي المتاحه
للسكن مع عجز في الوحدات السكنيه بما
يقارب مئه الف وحده سكنيه
تحت ظلال الاموات يلعب اطفال بيوت الصفيح
غير مدركين لحجم الماساه بعد هنا تتمثل
حقيقه مزاحمه قبول الاموات حيث تعيش عائله
كحيل المكونه من سبعه افراد في مسكن
متواضعه بالطرف الشرقي للمقبره بني البيت
على قبري شخصين مجهولي الهويه حتى صار
جزءا من اساساته الظروف الاقتصاديه الصعبه
فرضت على العائلات التاقلم مع تلك الحياه
طالب بيت انا مش اقدر انه بيتويني ويتوي
اولادي واسلم هذا البيت للاوقاف وارحم
القبور من العذاب تبعنا لانه القبور تعبوا
اصلا اقول لك يخلف عليهم انهم القبور
استحملونا يخلف عليهم البني ادمين الطيبين
اللي برا ما استحملوناش هم استحملونا يمكن
احنا نرحمهم لما نطلع من هنا من اولادنا
عليهم
مش عارف غير هيك ولادي كمان يعني شويه
صغيره مرضى نفسيين كلهم بالكامل لانه هذا
مش حياه